I am right now in bonus iris Argentina
let me take this place is beautiful
yesterday I did a meet-up with a bunch
of guys they showed up I sent a message
on Instagram three hours later bunch
people showed up outside of the hotel
and we had a great conversation together
and one of the entrepreneurs asked me
this question he said look he had just
gotten married a month ago and he's
running a business consulting business
IT consulting business and they're doing
good just three years ago they were
losing money two years ago they were
profiting 2 grand a month right now
they're profiting $10,000 a month in
Argentina that's a lot of money in
Argentina right now the sales tax alone
in Argentina is 21% their property tax
is roughly 3 percent and their income
tax it's 35% it's what they got going on
right now in Argentina their inflation
right now is 30 percent inflation it is
it's some number like 21 million people
and Argent's you know who can work total
populations like 45 million 21 million
people in Argentina who can work out of
the 21 million only 8 million work to
support the other 13 million that's a
number what's taking place right now in
Argentina yes what socialism does taxes
goes up you work the rest get taken care
of by the few that work it's a
challenging place to be but just ask me
a question it's about what do you think
about this I want to go into real estate
should I go into real estate I said
there why are you looking into real
estate if I see all these other people
doing so good I'm realist I'm thinking
about maybe I should go into real estate
I said look what is a couple sports that
Argentina's known for that you guys are
the best and he said soccer I said
polo as well right he said yes just so
you know about polo polo was founded in
Iran to all my Persian bodies that keeps
enemy messages on Instagram and snap but
nine out of the top 10 best polo players
in the world are in Argentina and the
one who's not is from Uruguay but he
plays in the Argentine League as well
what's the point here see Argentina
specialized in polo and soccer America
we specialize in basketball ok you know
Brazil specializes also in soccer the
Dominican Republic baseball look at the
kind of people they produce Russia
Canada maybe ha
right you look at Iran wrestling Iran
every year in the Olympics if you face
Iran they typically win the gold medal
in wrestling and weightlifting and
sometimes karate why they specialized
what's the points here if you want to
compete in the top 1% of 1% of 1% in any
field it takes a lot of momentum and a
lot of patience and many years of just
doing and refining your game can't
imagine if Argentina right now the
decider said we want to compete a
producer best baseball players in the
world honestly how long do you think it
would take before our shins gonna start
to produce on the best baseball players
one year 20 years 50 years how long has
America been trying to win the World Cup
how long how many times have we wanted
yet it's a different story this doesn't
mean don't give an effort and try but
the idea is anybody that specializes
goes to the top of the field and the top
one percentile most people don't want to
do it most people want to kind of get
good at a lot of things oh my God look
what she's doing oh my god I should go
into this no maybe I should do this I
should do digital mark I said do I'm
gonna be like this guy and they spend
their entire lives trying to be other
people where this guy who went from zero
and prophecy to two thousand to ten
thousand and it's killing it now it's
trying to look into real estate he's got
32 employees I told him focus go to two
three more years and see what happens
then keep scaling your business you're
doing good and then if you want to do
real estate by realists if you don't
have to meet your business maybe
someone's gonna be interesting want to
buy your business so moral the story
focus specialize don't get distracted
and I got a video I want you to watch if
this topic is something you want to get
better at the videos title is what's
more important size or position click on
a link here to go watch that video take
everybody bye-bye